pas encore deezer ces candidats sont
impatients ce lycée mort passe bien
propose les résultats de la filière
baccalauréat sciences et technologies de
la santé et du social qu'est la mention
assez bien et je suis vraiment étonné
parce que franchement avoir 12 e bac a
alors que je pensais avoir dit ça en
fait
et franchement je suis choqué et tenez
moi même et est fière de moi j'y croyais
pas on est au final je les tue vraiment
très contente parce que je croyais
vraiment pas du tout des rires des
larmes scène habituelle en ce mois de
juillet pour les 17500 yvelinois
candidats au concours cette année
ce jour là les résultats se partage
entre amis mais aussi avec parents et
professeurs on était confiant à la
travailler toute l'année et elles
méritent ce résultat on est très fier
d'elle
bachir à vis une sale et la pat mccabe
rattrapage beaucoup de mentions monsieur
assez bien mention bien donc belle
réussite pour cette classe suivante pour
ces bacheliers c'est maintenant l'heure
des vacances pour ceux dont la moyenne
est entre 8 et 10 ce sera le rattrapage
jusqu'au vendredi 8 juillet